do I believe that the barington
decoration premise of letting the virus
rip through society and infect people
leading to their illness hospitalization
and death is nonsense and
dangerous I still do it's absolute
propaganda so as you said as you
described it is an accurate description
of what we did said and wrote in the
great Bron declar we were not calling
for letting the virus rip uh and and uh
the evidence was very clear that that
the lockdowns especially in the spring
had had failed to protect older and
vulnerable people from there many many
many older vulnerable people had died
from the virus despite the lockdowns